only plans is when a data consistently
makes plans only to consistently cancel
them in fact 52 percent of singles say
they've been canceled on because of
something like a work emergency or too
much traffic have you ever been canceled
on for a date yeah
um I I do feel like on a dating app
though it is much more about the Chit
Chat and the talking about the ideas and
then I've even had someone make a plan
and like like let me know 30 minutes
before they're bailing I'm like really I
hate that don't do it 30 minutes before
I do it like a day before oh I've had
people do it like when I'm at the
restaurant waiting for yeah yeah and you
know what I thought to myself great more
appetizers for me I don't care I If
You're Gonna Keep you're the kind of
person who's gonna cancel on me thank
you for letting me know you know what I
mean and stay home and go I'm good move
on on to the next